voilà le genre je t'en prie nous
appelons tous invités je vous en prie
monsieur vous en prie bien sûr je ne
dirais pas votre nom parce que vous
exercez une profession qui finalement
est une profession d'un genre un peu
particulier vous tenez à garder
l'anonymat
c'est exact oui c'est ça alors je crois
qu'on peut il faut dire tout de suite
votre votre profession elle est bien les
bizarre je croyais pas que ça existait
finalement vous êtes très nombreux à
l'exil à l'exercer vous êtes
je suis manifestants professionnels
alors vous manifestez donc comme quoi ça
consiste à écouter non c'est un c'est un
peu un lieu commun de dire ça mais enfin
écoutez simplement pour être
manifestants professionnels
il faut d'abord faire des études je veux
dire que vous manifestez d'abord il faut
me dire où et pourquoi vous êtes
manifestants beau senna je crois que
c'est parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont
beaucoup de qui ont beaucoup d'idées
revendique à midi fonds qu'ils
voudraient protester et qui finalement
ont pas le temps de le faire parce
qu'ils travaillent alors ccc ccc ccc
notre gueule il ya des tas de gens qui
disent moi je ferais bien la grève mais
c'est embêtant parce qu'il faut que
j'aille au boulot alors il faut placer
les choses pour les manifestations
nous devons nous devons nous trouver
dans tous les endroits où il ya groupe
oui vous voyez dans tout l'est dans
toutes les petites réunions et tout
absolument tout vous faites de la petite
réunion de cinq six personnes juste trop
grand meeting à charléty shesha nous
essayons au maximum de boer est d'accord
alors pour être
manifestants professionnels il faut
faire des études alors que c'est ça
alors il faut passer d'abord par une
école c'est cette école s'appelle l'idem
l'institut des hautes études de
manifestations alors là je crois que
c'est un cycle de deux années c'est ça
vous avez un cycle de deux années
d'études
mais pendant la première forcément ce
sont des cours théoriques
naturellement vous avez apprentissage et
confection de la banderole confection de
pancartes
j'avais aussi apprentissage de slogans
de slogans politiques tels que paix en
israël où réhausser les salaires ou
encore cherbourg avec nous les vedettes
ne passeront pas c'est ça vous avez
aussi par la lime on est était malade
tout toutes ces choses qu'on est on se
doit de l'être au cours d'une
manifestation
je crois que ça c'est uniquement la
théorie ça c'est la théorie la théorie
comment faire les banderoles comment
tenir le sait ça le fanion l'euphonium
et uniquement alors par des dessins et
par les notes qui vous prenez la
deuxième année les travaux pratiques
c'est ça la deuxième année c'est
carrément la pratique alors vous avez
formation de cortèges des formations de
cortège vous avez des stages les stages
dans les formations politiques de gauche
et de droite je n'est ce pas et vous
avez lancement du passé vous avez vous
avez
j'imagine que vous avez également
protection contre la matraque
je vous m'avez couper la parole je sais
exactement ce que vous avez à ce que
vous avez utilisation du couvercle de
poubelle
surtout surtout la poubelle et vous avez
aussi fort comment dire apprentissage de
confection de cocktails molotov ah oui
qui est intéressant c'est très sain
porte je suppose que le port du lot port
du casque est obligatoire
il y de veegaete le dis ça pour les
jeunes gens qui pour les parents qui
voudraient que leur lançant de viol
manifestants professionnels étaient au
départ pendant tout l'exercice pratique
c'est pas dangereux dangereux produits
tout est alors est ce que en fin d'année
vous avez des diplômes avril donc en fin
d'année serait bien sûr en fin d'année
sa récompense bien sûr les meilleurs
élèves
vous avez par exemple le prix georges
séguy qui récompense le meilleur
manifestants de gauche ou le meilleur
coupures de courant vous avez ensuite le
prix tixier vignancour qui récompense le
meilleur manifestants de et remise du
courant chacun
je ne vous le fais pas dire oui bien sûr
vraiment dégoûté eux
voilà je vous remercie je m'excuse à je
vais être obligée d'arrêter l'interview
parce que là j'ai une manifestation à 8
heures pour la paix en israël et à 9h
pour elf atteint dans forcément les
dernières petites questions justes
puisque puisque vous partez
qu'est ce qui se passe parce qu'il peut
y avoir des retards imaginer par exemple
que la manifestation d'israël se
termineront à 9h15 9h20 seulement alors
c'est un problème parce qu'il ya plus
personne à l'autre il faut bien sûr il
vous tiendra ce moment là on se fait
remplacer on peut se faire en terre oui
c'est ça vous n'êtes pas titulaire d'une
manifestation c'est interchangeables
vous pouvez vous faire par exemple ce
soir n'admettant va la première
manifestation où il ya des encombrements
vous pouvez pas vous garer tout ça vous
perdez du temps alors qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous faites là je
téléphone à mon beau-frère les votre
beau frère est également
manifestons pour gestuelle non non ils
exercent une profession on n'arrive pas
je veux dire il ya peu au courant quand
même de quoi il sait comment on chaque
jour dans ces cas-ci fait les flics